amen
so the first song we're going to sing is
psalms number 27.
um
the lord is my light
[Music]
the lord is my light and my
the lord salvation
the strength of my life
of whom shall i be afraid
go in holy and camp against me
[Music]
this will i be confident
of the lord
all the days of my life
hear o lord when i cry with my voice
have mercy upon me when my father and my
mother
forsake me
then the lord will take me up
wait on the lord be of good courage
he shall strengthen thy heart
[Music]
[Applause]
the lord is my light
[Music]
do we have any selections
psalms 46.
[Music]
god is our refugee
[Applause]
god is a very present help in
therefore
not we fear
[Music]
with us
the god of jacob is our refuge
come
behold the works of the lord
[Music]
the lord of hosts
with us
the god of jacob is our refuge
come
behold all the works of the lord come
behold the works of the lord
[Music]
there is a river the streams whereby
blood
may
[Music]
he shall help her
the god of jacob is our refuge
come
[Music]
of the behold
come
behold the works of the lord
be still and know
that i am god
i will be
exalted in the earth
exalted in the
[Music]
stays with us
the god of jacob is
[Music]
thank you guys for singing
i want to thank the song leaders for
leading out this afternoon
and
let's bow our heads as we pray father in
heaven thank you so much for this
opportunity on this sabbath to
remind us of creation and our redemption
and we pray that this afternoon
that your holy spirit would attend us as
we engage in conversation dialogue
questions
and we thank you for this opportunity
for pastor skeet to share with us in
this way we ask for your divine presence
to attend us for we ask these things in
the precious name of jesus christ
amen
this afternoon it's open mic
and there's a microphone on this side
and
and that side
and it's an opportunity for us to engage
with pastors skeet and ask questions
that may be on our heart
and since no one's running to the mic
right now i'll ask my question here we
go
i had the privilege of
knowing pastor skeet when i was a
student at andrews university and on the
weekends
i just happened to room with
the program director for campus
ministries
and it was israel and so he said hey
come on out on the weekends you can help
teach some missionaries and there was a
double-wide mobile home
there outside of ann arbor
uh two of them
and on sabbath we would eat
rice and and beans i remember that
and
anyways uh there was there was a certain
culture of
a statement like higher than the highest
remember that i remember one year the
the mantra was higher than the highest
after the book education higher than the
highest human thought can reach is god's
ideal for his children
and
uh
i think that one of the things that i
drew from every talk or being around you
praise the lord
is that
there is this
this element of excellence
that
that exudes
you mentioned in your talk earlier
that
that christians should be known for
their excellence
and
there's almost this mentality sometimes
that you can be a christian and slovenly
and and late
uh
lack of attention to detail
uh sloppy work and so forth uh could you
talk a little bit more about
about being ambitious for the master's
glory
excellence
higher than the highest human thought
can reach and how that can be
incorporated into the christian life not
for our own glory but for god's glory
surely
ella white makes a very interesting
comment in the book
desire of ages page 72 paragraph four
speaking about jesus christ she said
he was not willing to be defective even
in the use of tools
he was as perfect a workman as he was in
character
now pause and think of what she just
said
what she's saying is that when jesus
christ who by training and trade was a
carpenter when he applied himself to the
making of a chair or a table or whatever
he applied it with the same care with
which he took care of his personal
character which we know to have been
sinless and so she said
he was as perfect a workman
as he was
in character
the desire of ages page 72 paragraph
four this is an astonishing statement it
is all the more astonishing when we
realize the life of christ in human form
is an example for us
not most of the life the very life he
lived in
human flesh is an example for you and
him for me but of course we have to
believe that the bible says see is thou
a man
diligent in his business
proverbs 22 29
he shall stand before kings
he shall not stand before mean men
if you study daniel 6 when darius chose
daniel to be the head of the princes
or the governors he chose him because an
excellent spirit was in him that's what
the bible says and so darius dismissed
the fact that daniel was from another
ethnic group
what he saw
was the excellence in daniel
god cannot put a rubber stamp on
sloppiness and mediocrity he cannot do
that and so that's why i said a bit it
was yesterday or whenever it was
excellence is christian behavior because
ultimately
we are representing god
and so when god made the world as i said
genesis 1 31 and god saw everything that
he had made and behold it was very good
many years ago i went to barbados to see
my sister
and she lives in a little house and
there's a little front yard
and someone
uh mowed the front yard i hesitated to
use the word more because there was no
lawnmower
when i saw it i said to her who did this
yard
because the grass was cut round between
rocks that could not be pulled up and i
was just aston i who
did this that was my first response and
then she told me who it was a brother
from the local church and i said to
myself the impression it made on me the
thoroughness
with which he did that job
would have drawn me to his church more
than any argument he possibly could have
made of course he's already one of us
and so what i'm saying to you my young
friends and my not so young friends
excellence
is required of god's people as a matter
of fact god requires more excellence
from you than he does from the
unbeliever
because you and i have the benefit of
contact with christ
and the unbeliever does not the same way
ours is personal his is more general
because god so loved the world our
connection with christ is personal
consequently we should feel the duty
to be excellent in whatever we do
if we were to do that
we will be the most prized employees in
any work environment
we will be the best students in any
classroom setting
we'll be the best neighbors in any
residential setting
excellence in all that we do
is required of us by god because this is
part of the image of god there is and
was never will be any mediocrity in god
and it should not be seen in god's
people now let me say quickly because
this is an academic environment does
that mean you get all a's in your
classes no
it simply means that when you've done
your work you've done the very best you
can do
now that's a b fine but you know you see
sabbath keeping is connected to weekly
excellence
you say to yourself or to me what do you
mean
listen to verse 31 of genesis 1 let me
pray fathers i speak to your people
tell me what to tell them i pray please
in jesus name amen and god saw
everything that jimmy made
and behold it was very good
then he rested
he rested from a week
of excellent work
when you and i do sloppy work during the
week we know it's been sloppy
then we really can't keep the sabbath
what are you resting from
are you with me you can't rest from
sloppiness you can't rest from that what
are you resting from you you see the
rest must be physical and mental in
other words you must be able to say look
i looked at my week of duties i have
done all i could only god could have
done more
you rest
your conscience isn't bothered
you did not shortcut your employer or
your teacher or your parents i have done
all that i could when the woman anointed
the feet of christ and the disciples
rebuked he said leave her alone she had
done what she could
and all she did was wash her feet
she has done what she could and so all
i'm saying to you is in all that you put
your hand to do an i
make a conscious effort
to do the very best
particularly
in the spiritual area of the life
but if you and i do it in the
educational the social the environmental
it will spill over into the spiritual
the most important of all
we serve a savior
who demonstrated excellence
we must regard excellence
not simply as something we do
but something we are
thank you
uh
oh there you go
yes i um
uh i i want to ask how do you memorize
scripture
i was hoping someone surprised me not
asked me that but i
it takes hard work my handsome brother
hard work
and i'm not joking hard work
i was invited to go to house for food
dr judas palace
and
i was on the outside reading bible
verses while waiting for the food
to be picked or cooked or
gathered like manna
and i was just going through some
passages
i took the food to my place
and i was going through some passages
when i finished eating
i put on some music there's some there
are some bible passages i recite to
pieces of music i put that on and i
started reciting i started reciting
reciting reciting so when i need it it
will come to me like that
ella white writes in
my character and personality volume 2
page 601 paragraph 4
that which at first seems difficult
by constant repetition grows easy
and right thoughts and actions become
habitual
the same way sin becomes habitual
right thoughts and actions can become
habitual but no one becomes a demon
overnight
no one becomes a saint overnight it
takes practice in demon
whatever or practice in righteous
behavior and so what i recommend to you
is
constant constant practice you may also
write verses on three by four take them
with you and say them i just say them
look way look look look away
that's how i do it but i do it all
day
virtually
when i'm brushing my teeth i say a
chapter
when i'm showering
i recite a chapter or a passage you see
you learn to do several things at the
same time here i am taking a shower
that's let's say five minutes
what else can i do with those five
minutes
i can recite some bible verses
i'm driving somewhere unless you're
driving from amity to a little rock how
long is that two hours
what else can you do but just look at
the road are you following me or chat
with someone next to you you recite
bible verses if you only know one john
11 35 jesus swept you say it and you
think about it you think what is the
message in this verse for me and so what
i recommend but ask god to give you see
when you desire something no one can
stop you
when the builders of the tower of babel
the bible says and the lord came down to
see the city and the tower which the
children of men build it genesis 11
verse 5 and the lord said behold the
people is one
and have of all one language and this
they begin to do and now
nothing will be restrained from them
which they have imagined to do they were
so determined to build that tower god
said the only power in the universe that
can stop them that's me
he says nothing will be restrained from
them
yes
i'm sure you heard of young people who
jump out the window to go see their
boyfriend or girlfriend they fight with
their parents nothing will restrain them
are you following me from seeing that
little boy little girl they love well
apply that god's word
but also understand the value
this is your chief weapon against
temptation
christ object lessons page 100 paragraph
one the scriptures are the great agency
in the transformation of character
jesus prayed sanctify them through thy
truth this is the truth what did jesus
tell the disciples in john 15 verse 3
now you clean through the word you
understand the word in your head not
only memorized like a poem but
functioning as a principle in your life
that is the victory that is the power
that intimidates satan and since you're
all young psalm 119 verse 9 wherewithal
shall a young man cleanse his ways our
young woman by taking he thereto
according to that we do not understand
the power of god's word is released
through the obedience of faith
the same power that said let there be
light and the light came is right in
your hand
elmight writes the same creative energy
that called the worlds into existence is
in the word of god this word imparts
power it begets life every command is a
promise accepted by the will received
into the soul it brings with it the life
of the infinite one it transforms the
nature and recreates the soul in the
image of god page 126 paragraph 4 of
education this is your power to conquer
satan this is your defense against the
overpowering deception that is already
coming on this earth this is your
victory studied and obeyed christ object
lessons page 100 paragraph one the last
statement says if studied and obeyed
they must go together the word of god
works in the heart subduing every unholy
attribute
you name the unholy attribute you're
wrestling with studied and obeyed
what does the devil do he doesn't get
you to rob banks he just take you away
from the word this all
take them from the word let them go to
church
let them go over there canvassing
let them have no time for the word
that's all
now he'd be delighted if you blew up
buildings and whatever but the
fundamental thing is get them from the
word and you have them
they'll be decent vegetarians on the way
to hell because they had no time for the
word of god
this
and our seventh-day adventist this plus
the precious council of ellen white
sometimes i pray i thank god
for elohim's ministry
i thank god for the ministry of the
pioneers and otherwise said read what
they wrote because they study the word
in the way we do not understand my young
friends
this by the way
this will improve your academic
performance christ object lessons page
125 paragraph three
if
the follower of christ
will believe his word
and practice it
there is no science in the natural world
he will not be able to grasp and
appreciate what does that mean grass
means understand appreciate me is
connected with the great creator if the
follower of christ
will believe his word and true belief
requires action and practice it there is
no science in the natural world he will
not be able to grasp and appreciate
want to do better
here's your secret because it
strengthens the mind
and it makes comprehension much easier
i recommend
the word of god
as your strength
your light what should i do thy word is
a lamp unto my feet and a light unto my
path what direction should i take psalm
25 4 show me thy ways of lord teach me
thy powers this
is you see
sorry for taking so long this question
tell me if this makes sense
how was the heavens made
by the word how was the earth made
then
can you not see if you've been placed in
a universe
made by the word
there is no other life to live to be
consistent with god's universe than to
live
by the word
and so jesus says man shall not live by
bread alone but by every word
the same word that created the universe
the same word that sustains the universe
ii peter 3 7 is the word by which you
and i should live
this is life
all right
yes okay this isn't my question but
um
why should
it's a question on modesty why should
women wear skirts and dresses
and can you show from the bible and also
spiritual prophecy as well why should
women wear skirts and dresses
all right
modesty
is a is a difficult concept to define in
precise terms because modesty varies
from culture to culture
i've been to india
on a couple of occasions
an indian lady may come into church and
all of this is exposed
but that's modest
in india
that's not bodis in little rock are you
following me
so don't tell me i saw a woman no no no
that's modest in india i was in ghana
and there was a guy on the pulpit
he seemed to be wrapped in a bed sheet
it wasn't a bed sheet but look just wrap
this around and and most of this out and
but that's modest
in ghana
and so modesty depends on where you are
but there is a unifying theme regarding
modesty and that theme is the holy
spirit of god
the spirit of god will guide and you see
the church cannot provide microscopic
guidance in every little detail of the
believer's life there must be room for
the spirit of god to say don't do that
don't do that don't do that
and so what i recommend to you is you
ask
last night i said
everything must be done for the glory of
god
before you dress
before you buy us outfit dress pants
whatever shoes
before you go to the barber for a
hairstyle you ladies meant to
ask god
father
is this for your glory
if it's not
keep waiting for the spirit to convict
you i was in namibia
and i was talking to young people one
sunday morning
and i stress the principle of for the
glory of god without exception where you
dress your hair your shoes your
relationships your foo every single
thing
will this glorify god and it was a young
lady present
she had a
a hairstyle
i mean this thing was huge i like to
call it an eagle's nest sitting on her
head that's the way it looked
and i said okay all right next morning i
was doing one-to-one counseling and she
came and i didn't recognize her
she said you recognize me i said no she
said i am the lady who had this oh i
said what happened she said as i
listened to you
i was convicted because i realized i did
not make this choice for the glory of
god
i was simply following fashion
and she cut it off the very day
went off into canvassing i mean just a
conviction on hairstyle took her into
canvassing
and medical missionary work she was
convicted i was in bermuda conducting a
weaker prayer and this guy came every
day he's a rastafarian
he has these tread locks and you know
okay
jesus died for the whole world not just
for people were here or know here and so
he came he came
the sabbath morning for baptism he went
to the back of the church
and came back and nobody recognized him
he had brought his scissors to church
with him
something in the weaker prayer convicted
this man he cut the whole thing off
because he knew honestly
that this was not for god's glory let me
tell you what's missing in many of our
decisions honesty
we will not be honest with ourselves i
chose that shoe because i want to look
good i was not thinking of god's glory
at
all
let me tell you this guaranteed if you
ask first
is this for the glory of god
your choices will change all of this
about modesty modesty will be directed
by the spirit of god as you give
yourself to christ and allow him to
direct your choices whether it's a tie
or sure
i'm not an example of anything but let
me tell you
because i traveled a lot
i'm always on planes
eloise said to the preacher when the
preachers get up in a public show wear a
dark suit
because you make an effect even before
you open your mouth
you have an effect on people she said
let the effect be positive by the way
you look and all
experts in psychology will agree with
that now
and so i would ask god father
what ties should i wear
on the plane
literally
so i asked my wife which tie
i've stood in the bathroom with two or
three ties in my face said father which
one i've actually had ties on and then
taking them off because the spirit said
not that one
this one
that time may turn somebody off
literally
and so i ask
when i began doing that you will not
believe the thing the experiences i have
had
when i started asking god what shirt to
wear
and what tie
and what suit
i would ask him
now i can't say i heard a voice but you
get impressions
i was uh leaving i think it was nigeria
these things actually began happening to
me
and i'm coming down with my little
handbag dressed
and the immigration guy saw me coming he
said come bishop come
so i said to him when i got to the desk
why do you call me bishop
he said it's obvious you're a preacher i
said why do you say that he said the
anointing is all over you
and he took off his cap he said bless me
and so i dropped a blessing on him you
see
i was in south africa
these things began to happen and there i
was coming again through security and
the guy said to me come preacher
when i got to myself why do you call me
priest he said but you look like one
i said okay then i went to another
officer a little further down because
you have multiple security checks he
said come come preacher he didn't hear
my first interaction i said why do you
call me preach he said but you look like
one he said okay i was another trip to
south africa i was going to a canvas a
university campus to preach the students
university of waters ran outside
johannesburg in johannesburg we were
driving my drive and i and i told him
pull in by that gas station i wanted
some gum you know americans love chewing
gum so he pulled in and i went to one
little store like a 7-eleven and i said
do you have gum she said uh yes she gave
me the gum i said you have juice she
said no
so i got the juice
no i asked her for juice first with
juice
she went to get the juice and the juice
was
right next to the liquor
so i said uh you were close to the
liquor section is that juice you said i
would never give you a liquor i said why
not she said you're a preacher
so how do you know that she said it was
obviously a preacher
i went to the next store right next door
to get the gum
the guy said come bishop
so i said
i'm getting irritated now why do you
call me that he said but you look like
one
all this began to happen when i
literally began to ask god
what tie
what shirt
what suit
i'm not joking
what am i telling you ask god
when you stand in front of those dresses
which one should i pick
forget beyonce ask god
forget little nas ask god
what shirt should i buy you know forget
whomever ask god how should i fix my
hair ask him i'm telling you if you
listen he'll tell you not that
not that i've seen women in church on
high heels so high
i said lord if she wanted to commit
suicide she can just jump off those
shoes
she doesn't need a building are you
following me just jump off those shoes
and she's dead the things are so high
so i
ask god
are you with me and the lord will direct
you he'll speak to your conscience
all right
god bless you
let's go to the side
how do you have devotions
how
yeah like what do you do
no this is odd i have devotions all day
but i start in the morning yes
you know but all day
what do i mean by that
i am
i'm always on the road
going to supermarket wherever
and i'm always reciting bible verses i'm
thinking what does this say
what does this mean
trying to make connections between one
passage and another passage i'm
literally always doing it when i say
always i don't mean 24 hours a day every
minute i mean at least every hour
part of the hour i'm going through
passages either reviewing or trying to
learn new passages
and i'm thinking
a few questions what does this tell me
about jesus
because they are there which testify of
me what does this verse teach me about
christ the love of god what does it
teach me about righteousness the central
teaching of the gospel righteousness by
faith what christ does for the sinner
what how does it help me understand some
other passage
and as you recite and you learn and you
fill your head it's easy to compare this
verse with that verse and that verse
this verse and so literally all during
the day when i'm in the gym
you won't believe this but i'll tell you
let's say you're on the bench press you
do a set you know ten reps
and you take a minute to recover you
i said that's a waste of time just sit
there
let me recite the verse in the beginning
god created the heaven
so i started
literally
reciting passages while i'm recovering
so what i would do i would time some
passages usually the psalms
i will lift up mine eyes into the hills
from its or revelation 15 and see okay
this takes 40 seconds i'll say it twice
and i do that
so the time is used
you understand what i'm trying to say
and so i uh that my devotion begins in
the morning but it also goes during the
day
you'll ask my wife she'll tell us and as
i go to the darkest part of the house
turn off all the lights and sit on the
floor
and just start thinking
of uh
turn off all the lights so you have no
distractions no nothing
think of a bible verse think on it
what does this say father just dwell on
it dwell on it dwell on it something
else i do that's devotional
i've i'm trying to connect everything to
the bible
for instance
let's say i'm wearing a linen shirt
our cotton shirt where does cotton come
from
a plant
when were plants made
on the third day
am i right am i wrong yes and so you
make a connection immediately between
your shirt and creation are you with me
was it sunny today
it is still sunny
when was the sun made
on day four
who is the son of righteousness
jesus christ
you make that spiritual connection have
you ever driven down the street and you
saw a dead deer dead rabbited dead
something we call it roadkill
how did death enter the world
sin
because the curse of adam affected not
only adam otherwise said his rebellion
passed to the animal kingdom and so they
die
and so you
a bird flies by they were made on the
fifth day
one day i too will fly through the
atmosphere what i'm trying to tell you
try to make a spiritual connection with
every single if you do that your mind is
so constantly employed with that which
is spiritual the devil is always having
to wait
wait
until she thinks about a rock song wait
until he starts rapping then i can come
in
keep the mind on this you see a human
being they were made on the sixth day
as by one man's sin entered into the
world and death by sin christ became
human you have a fight with your mother
or your father
yeah didn't lucifer fight with his
creator jesus christ yes every single
thing
what is the spiritual connection
and in classroom what's the spiritual
connection in the classroom don't pursue
a grade first pursue a deeper knowledge
of god
now you didn't get what i said let me
say it again
i'm not telling you don't care what
grade you get because i earlier said
excellence god requires i'm saying to
you is let your pursuit of a grade
travel on the track of your pursuit of a
deeper knowledge of god
if you're studying biology
who created life
why do you hesitate who created life god
now you ask yourself where is god
in this cell
where is god in anaerobic respiration
where is god
in gaseous exchange in the lungs because
every creator every artist leaves his or
her fingerprints
if you're a musician you can listen to
music and say that's mozart
oh that's handled you look at a painting
that's michelangelo that's whoever
that's picasso
it's the same with god isaiah 6 3 the
whole earth is full of his glory psalm
19 1 the heavens declare the glory of
god and so all of the heaven the glory
of god all of the earth the glory of god
despite pollution you look for god in
accounting didn't he arrange the tithing
system
offering your
everything you study
ly says whatever line of investigation
we pursue with a sincere knowledge to
arrive at truth we are brought into
communion with that mighty unseen
intelligence because all legitimate
knowledge flows from god i say
legitimate crime is not a legitimate
knowledge it did not originate with god
all branches of legitimate knowledge
from accounting to zoology originate
with god and so what i'm telling you
pursue a deeper knowledge of god
and if you do it selflessly the great
will come
it changes your motivation but the
outcome is the same
because god sees now she's looking for
me in this physics class he's looking
for me in this math class she's looking
for me in this history class i'm a god
of prophecy and the lord will bless your
efforts search for a deeper knowledge of
god
the great will come
amen
we'll just switch off sides here so on
this side do we have a question on the
side
so uh i know that there's no
contradictions in the bible say that
again
i know there's no contradictions right
right and i'm just trying to figure this
one out this is in deuteronomy 23 verse
and it says in ammonite or moabite shall
not enter into the congregation of the
lord
even to their tenth generation
they shall not enter into the
congregation of the lord forever and so
i'm just wondering how did king david
become a king if he was uh like a fourth
generation moabite he's a what
a fourth generation mobile it wasn't
ruth his great great yes yes yeah now
that i can answer i can't answer that i
have to look into that i can answer that
now yeah i can i can't but you're right
the bible has no contradiction the
contradiction exists in our heads there
has to be an answer for that but i can't
give it now okay yeah sorry sorry sorry
all right let's go to this side
is it okay to kill in self-defense or
say if you are in the army
what if you if you are working on the
army no no no no
we are what's the expression um
conscientious objectives were
non-combatants 70 atmospheres we go as
medics we go in any role that does not
require taking a life
because
even if you weren't a christian do you
really understand why you're fighting
do you really and
government can tell you whatever it
wants do you really understand why
you're about to kill another 18 year old
who himself does not understand why he's
shooting at you but as a christian no no
taking of life
um adventists are non-combat that goes
all the way back to the 1860s we're
non-combatants
we don't kill people we don't kill
people
we have a god who can defend us not even
in self-defense
you can defend without killing
god is not sleep god can defend remember
when 50 men came to get elijah and god
sent fire consumed him
ahab sent 50 more god sent fire consumed
them the next 50 that came said please
come with us they were very nice they
said please come this elijah said okay
god defends his people and he is he
taught us that in several ways when the
israelites are not israelites well i can
refer to them but gideon when gideon was
called by god to deliver israel from the
midianites gideon raised an army of 33
000 men god said no no no no too many
because if you win you did it so it will
look reduced that number he reduces to
10 000. too many he reduced 33 000 to
and they never raised the sword you sort
of get a pitcher a lantern and a trumpet
the armies killed themselves
he never raises they never is the sword
eloise said it was never god's will that
the israelites should conquer by warfare
but by plain and simple obedience and
when god destroyed the egyptian army in
the red sea he was demonstrating i will
take care of your enemies
you
obey me when the devil came to tempt job
and when god said hast thou considered
my servant job a perfect and an upright
man one that feareth god and esther with
evil then satan answered the lord and
said does job fair god for not hath not
thou made a hedge about him and about
his house and about all that he hath on
every side
a hedge of protection because job is
obedient we don't kill
we don't maim
we trust god
and god has mighty angels who can
intervene on our behalf
thank you
steve
um i have a question that
um actually isn't really my question but
it's a question that's uh
that a lot of people have nonetheless
um
basically it's
if you've been praying for someone for a
long time say since when you're very
very young
and there seems to be no apparent change
you know saying like if they
say if you have a mother or father is
not a christian or things like that all
right
so how do you not lose heart or what do
you what do you do okay all right let's
pray again father as i continue to
answer questions help me tell me what to
tell your people whom you love in jesus
name i pray amen
moses's life is divided into three
sections what are the three sections
yes the first 40
the next 40 in the wilderness first in
egypt the next 40 leading the israelites
let's look at the middle 40 it took god
40 years
to get out of moses what he'd learned in
egypt
now
if god took 40 years
i can pray for 20. are you following me
because i'm praying on an issue that's
precisely god's will
but the long praying may end up changing
me
not just the person i'm praying for it
may end up changing me you see god
cannot be fully understood counts now by
searching find out god god may realize
the person you're praying for i've got
that person covered i want you changed
and by putting you in a situation where
you need to pray you may change
isaac prayed for 20 years before he got
a son
if you read genesis 25 20 and isaac was
40 years old when he took rebecca to
wife the daughter of bethuel the syrian
of peter naram the brother the to laban
the syrian now
that's genesis 25 verse 20.
in verse 26 verse
26 yes
of the same chapter and isaac was three
school years when she bare them
he married her when he was 40
she had them in 60. he prayed 20 years
genesis 12 verse 5 and abram was set
twelve verse four neighbor was 175 years
old when he came into canaan 75
we know he was 100 years old when he had
isaac how long did he pray
25 years
the object of praying
the primary object of praying is not to
get something from god
the primary object of praying is to
fellowship with god
are you with me
we must stop seeing god as an atm
machine
god loves to fellowship when you pray
you are hanging out with god
when you study the bible you're hanging
out with god the father god the son god
the holy ghost and the angels now why do
i say that
in daniel chapter 8 and i heard a man's
voice between the banks of oolai which
called and said gabriel make this man to
understand the vision daniel 8 verse 16
god told gabriel help daniel to
understand the word are you with me when
you study the word angels are sent
but jesus said in john 16 13 how be it
when he the spirit of truth is come he
will guide you into all truth we have
the spirit and the angels assisting you
in acts chapter 8. the angel told philip
take that way
when philip got near to the chariot of
the ethiopian you know the spirit said
go to the chariot we have angel and
spirit associated with someone
understanding the word when you study
god's word you are hanging out with god
and the spirit
and the son who himself is the word and
the angels
when you pray
you are fellowshipping with god it is
not just gimme gimme gimme
yes there's a time for give me give me
give me but praying cannot be seen as a
transactional event it is fellowship
with god
spending time
in god's divine presence so that we
emerge with our faces shining like moses
after 40 uninterrupted days of exposure
to god's glory
when you're praying for someone's
salvation you pray until you die or the
person dies
the bible says in ii peter chapter 3
verse 9 the lord is not slack concerning
his promise as some men come slackness
but is
long-suffering to us word
one of the qualities of god is he's long
suffering not willing that any should
perish but it all should come to
repentance if god is long suffering we
are ideally made in the image of god we
should be what
long suffering
pray for that person pray for that
person and remind god
you said first timothy chapter 2 verse 4
i will have all men to be saved and to
come unto the knowledge of the truth you
remind god if anything is god's will it
is the salvation of your husband who
left you your wife your children who are
out in the world your whomever god wants
to save that person calvary is proof
keep praying but remember
whether you remember or not
the act of praying
ideally will change you
not just the person for whom you're
praying
keep praying
keep praying please the bible says pray
without ceasing that's not symbolic
that's literal it mean always in contact
with heaven
thanks for the question next one
did you have a question
everything you're saying is
a lot about righteousness by faith
and i know you study a lot of ellen
white so
when she says that if they had followed
the 1880 message we would have already
been gone to heaven
can you talk about that i i it's really
important how
if that's the case
why don't we study more of what they
said and have you studied that much i
don't hear you talking about that much
because i listen to you a lot
i'd like to hear more about that
no one can say why the church does not
well we can't say the church does not
because we don't know what the entire
church body does around the world elo
white on two occasions said that christ
would have come back
after 1888 and shortly after some in the
early 50s she made a similar statement
now when the israelites went into the
wilderness it was not god's will they
spent 40 years
he wanted to take them directly to cain
and land unbelief allowed him to cause
him to curse them it was a curse and
sent them back into the wilderness 40
years the same with us unbelief
yes eloy said that
and it's it's tragic that the church did
not respond as the church should have
responded to the message of
righteousness by faith it didn't and
here we are today
there's nothing to prevent us from
studying
as individuals
what was taught you see as individuals
you see we're not saved as a church
uh mind character and personality volume
2 page 4 23 paragraph 2 the gospel deals
with individuals
i run across a lot of people the church
has no outreach program the church i
said well you do
i one do you need your family to tell
you how to get along with your friend or
how to arrange and automate a friend why
do you need the church the church
doesn't help you sin why does the church
need to help you to do something that's
right you know figure out something that
you can do for god without the church
one day the church structure will no
longer exist as it is what will we do
don't wait for the church i can't answer
why the church does not nor can i say
the church does not because i don't know
what the entire church does north south
east and west now it may not appear to
be a popular subject yes
but
we must take
individual decisions make individual
decisions to study that which tends to
bring us to christ and that which may
hasten the second coming of jesus christ
we must make personal decisions to do
that yes my brother
i think rephrase is this on rephrasing
it would be
when the rubber hits the road
how do you overcome sin okay all right
let's get into that that's the 1880
message what you basically preach but
i don't know why you don't bring jones
and wagner into it like because you
don't know what i don't know why you
don't bring
jones wagner's name into it because if
you study what they've
taught
you've got basically she said they said
it better than she could have
so i think that
everyone's arguing about oh they
apostasize all this
leave that alone that's storing the baby
out with a bath water
we need to understand what they said so
that we can be
come like christ okay all right all
right that's what i'm talking about now
when i preach about tithe i don't
mention jane andrews
but he was the one who worked out the
tithing for the church
when i preached about the state of the
dead i don't mention orl was in crozier
who worked i don't so if i talk about
righteousness by faith i don't have to
mention jane andrews the only one i
really mentioned frequently is ellen
white
but i can accept what they've said
without mentioning a name or giving
credit to them credit goes to god
again
the question is how do you overcome sin
by the righteousness of christ because
the sinless life of christ is the power
that enables us and that power is
mediated through the word of god you
know when the sinner brought let me pray
again father please be with me and all
of us listening let truth triumph i pray
in jesus name amen you read leviticus
chapter one let's go leviticus one let's
read from verse one quickly quickly
quickly who has it who has it
where is joshua
my friend my little friend who was
sitting right here
oh hi josh
i just missed you from right here that's
all god bless you okay all right
joshua is my boy okay
do we have leviticus one
who has the virgo swan all right someone
read first king james version and the
lord called unto moses and spake unto
him you can come to the mic if you like
and read
out of the tabernacle of the
congregation saying what
speak speak unto the children of israel
and say unto
them if any man of you bring an offering
unto the lord you shall bring your
offering of the cattle even of the herd
and of the flock pause you've got to
bring an offering don't go stay there
you go you've got to bring an offering
that's important you have to bring an
offering now if it's offering beer
verse three
if his offering be a burnt sacrifice to
the herd let him offer a male without
blessing
let him offer a male
without blemish
how will he know the animal is without
blemish
come on how will he know the animal is
without blemish
he looks at it he examines it
now
verse 4
and he shall put his hand upon the head
of the burnt where does that happen
where does that happen
in the outer court yes who is there with
the person who brings the lamb the
priest what does the priest also have to
do
he has to examine
now listen to me carefully as we talk
about how do you conquer sin
two living beings enter the outer court
the sinner
and the lamb
are you following me
which one does the priest examine
the lamb
i'm talking to myself again
which one does the priest examine
the la not the guy
amen your salvation is based on how good
you are
it is based
on jesus but you have to
bring him
now
for god so loved the world that he gave
what you call that
a gift
yeah okay but i want the word gift
you're right but i want gift christ is a
gift to the world are you following me
not to be given back to god
so you bring the gift this is christ
the priest accepts christ
at a higher level
when you bring christ to god
god accepts christ and consequently
accepts you why because you've brought
christ you don't hand christ to god
it's not a long-distance transaction you
have given your life to christ that's
essential you bring to the father the
life of christ the righteousness of
christ which is sufficient for the
father the elohim i said it's not
important what god thinks of you
it's important what he thinks of jesus
but you've got to bring jesus
and hold on to him
so that you are accepted in
the beloved
are you listening to me
you bring jesus
and the man or the woman who brings
jesus can never be rejected by the
father
if you give yourself to him
and accept him as your savior then
sinful though your life may has been
for his sake
for his sake you're counted righteous
christ's character stands in place of
your character and you are accepted by
god just as if you had never sinned
steps to christ paid 62 paragraph two
you bring christ but when you bring
christ you're saying i accept the
righteous life of christ i accept
christ's life of submission to the
father i accept christ's life of
unselfish service i accept all of that
as mine
you don't hand christ to god and say
here he is
by bringing christ you accept you
believe
that christ can do for you his
righteousness is sufficient for you
because it is not your righteousness
because the righteousness that qualifies
you for place in god's kingdom is
sinlessness
the life of christ had no sin that
animal had no blemish the sinner had to
bring the animal and the animal was
accepted bring christ to god how do you
do that by surrendering to christ
and the person who is in christ
is accepted by the father but by
bringing christ you're saying i
surrender to christ i accept his
righteous life as everything the father
desires and if that's genuine that
righteous life in christ
works itself through you
that's the way it was for christ when he
was on the earth john 14 verse 10
believeth thou not that i am in the
father and the father in me the words
that i speak unto you i speak not of
myself but the father that dwelleth in
me
he doeth the works
when you accept christ it's christ in
you and you're in christ
as long as that union exists
you're safe
and if it is genuine and the only way it
can exist is if it's genuine the life of
christ will express itself through you
victory over sin
is the righteousness of christ
as a practical principle in your life
and that power is the word of god
are you with me the word of god because
god created by his word
god speaks righteousness by his word god
heals by his word he cast out demons by
his word christ himself is the word to
bring crisis to bring the word the word
of righteousness the word of life the
word of victory the word of everything
bring christ to god don't bring a church
don't bring a doctrine bring a person
that person is both man and god and you
come with christ to the father you say
father i come in the name of jesus
holding on to jesus
don't let go
that power of christ will transform you
but as jesus said in john 15
abide abide abide abide
keep holding on that's the secret keep
holding keep holding keep holding and
that keep holding is done by constantly
being in the word of god and in prayer
keep holding on to jesus
that which thou hast hold fast we're
told revelation twice hold fast
because the devil will try to break that
bond between you and your savior all
right somebody else jose
yes uh we watched
some of your video in biblical biblical
preaching class on how to preach we
learn how to preach without using
uh open note but we were able to use
open bible
but it seemed like you
preached oh without open note or open
bible
my bible is always open i mean i mean
you know not looking at it right right
how do you do it well i'm looking at it
here
read acts chapter 2.
that very powerful sermon one third of
that sermon is made up of old testament
quotations
peter did not have a bible
there was no personal bible in those
days you have to go to the synagogue and
luke chapter four and you're handed a
scroll
peter had no bible
one third of that sermon old testament
quotations they were here when christ
three times said it is written he had no
bible it was here
so you can read the bible off the scroll
of your head
are you with me
who asked that question
what's your address
okay
okay do you have it in front of you no
you're reading it off the scroll
do the same thing to god's word
good question god bless you
okay let's go over here
um so i have somebody that i know
and say that again i have somebody that
i know like they're you know my friend
and
they're into a lot of crime like stories
but like they're true stories um and
they listen to it a lot is that a sin to
be listening to that like even if it's
like very small amounts like is that
like a thing
i like that either it's a small amount
i'm very glad you said
this is a bottle of water nice clean
vitamin and rich water
if i drop one drop of arsenic into this
just one drop
would you drink it
you would
no
but it's just one drop now
how many sins did adam commit before he
was thrown out of the garden
one
i mean how many fruits did he eat well
maybe one maybe part of one
what adam did was not monstrous in our
sense of the word monster he did not rob
a bank
it wasn't suicide or genocide or
infanticide or whatever patricide or
matricide or
he just did what vegetarians do
he consumed a fruit
and was
and were thrown out of the garden so
when my lovely sister says even though
it's just a little bit that's all the
devil needs let me tell you something
you know why the bible consistently
tells us thou shalt love the lord thy
god with
all thy heart and with all thy soul with
all thy mine are with all thy strength
why because for god to save you listen
to me carefully he needs
all of you
to destroy you the devil just needs a
little peace
now you're not with me it's my fault
to save you
god needs
all of you
to destroy you satan just needs a piece
of you
so god says
give me your whole heart
thou shalt love the lord thy god with
all thy lord
all thy soul
all thy mind
all thy strength
all thy might that's what we do not do
and so we have a lot of decent people on
the way to hell
look at what they were doing in the days
of lot
likewise also luke 17 28 as it was in
the days of lot did it eat
they dry they bought they sold they
planted they built it which of those is
a crime none
living life as usual
but god wasn't first
lost
most people who are lost would be decent
people
for whom christ was not numero uno are
you following me my little sister my
young sister
a little bit of anything wrong is too
much
go to ephesians 5. let me show you
something exactly in line i'm so glad
you asked that question go to ephesians
5 someone else come to the mic with the
king james version ephesians 5
be therefore followers of god as their
children and walk in love
as christ also has loved us
and given himself for us and offering a
sweet smelling okay good read from verse
2 of verse 3 3 of ephesians 5. listen
carefully
but fornication
and unclean
carefully now let it not be once once
named among you has become not once
because once is too often
thank you very much child guidance page
200 paragraph two
that which
we do once
we are more apt to do again
that's a psychological principle
but you turn that around for the good
news
if you resist once
it's easy to resist the second time
then the third time it works both ways
and so a little of anything that's bad
is not good
catastrophic
disastrous that's how the devil gets you
little
many years ago this is actual true story
the only children's story i can tell
really i have only two children's
stories
i trained some squirrels to eat out of
my hand
and i would go to the backyard
and they'd come out of the trees
i saw them nuts and one in particular
would come closer than all the others i
said this fella is bold
he'd come closer he actually came up to
my hand
i held a nut just like this
he came up
and for the nut he missed the nut and
grabbed my finger
and i felt the power but he didn't bite
down he realized this wasn't the nut
then he switched his grip and he took
the nut i was grateful to god and so he
went off
the next day
he came and i kept doing that that was a
summer
then i put the nut in the palm of my
hand
and did that
and he came and his tail was swishing
back and forth who is this guy and he
then he put his two front paws right in
my hand
took the nut turned around and dashed
off to the trees and i said i've got him
and i kept on doing that then i kept
backing up i kept backing up now i lived
in the basement so there was a sliding
door and i stepped into the door
with a nut and he came now all the
orders in the house he could smell he
was nervous
took it out of my hand and ran
then i stepped but literally happened i
stepped back into the house he came into
the house
took that nut
that's how the devil does it
never overnight
one step
one step one step once before you know
it you look back you say wait a minute
how did i get this far
you got that far
one step at a time a little at a time
but reverse that that's how we grow in
grace one step at a time one step so
let's focus on that
ellen my sister right here
now we're supposed to go three to four
we have time okay
all right
go ahead sister so i'm asking this
question for a friend um you had
mentioned of how you memorize
bible text but can you go into more
detail on how or can you even like give
us an example on how you memorize
passages or even script
spread of prophecy okay uh i was let's
say when i was memorizing revelation 16.
what is found in revelation 16
let's have last place
if you go to that chapter because when
you memorize you must know where each
individual verse is when you need it you
can't be preaching i need a verse from
revelation 16. let me recite the whole
first the whole chapter till i get to
the verse you can't do that you have to
know which each verse is
i realize
plague number four is in verse eight
tell me if i'm right
plague number five is in verse 10.
plague number six where do you think it
is
verse 12 yes
and plague number seven where do you
think it is 17 no 17 17
7 17. and so those became markers for me
so i could find a plague now all i had
to do now was focus on the first three
are you with me
but four was in verse eight so you look
at the structure of the passage
for instance let's say when i was
working on daniel 8
in the third year of the reign of king
belshah
welsh a vision appeared unto me
even unto me daniel
after that which appeared unto me at the
first so they're three and two knees
so you look at that okay there are three
unto me
when you remember when i was memorized
genesis 5 and adam lived 130 years and
he got a son in his own likeness after
his image
and called his name seth and all the
days that adam lived for 930 years and
he died now there is a there's a pattern
to all of the patriots in genesis 5.
once you get that pattern it becomes
easy to plug in the numbers you see and
all the days of methuselah were nine
hundred six and nine years and he died
all the days of limit was seven hundred
seven or seventy years and he died you
you see the formula and you then plug in
the numbers and that comes along with of
course constant constant repetition with
ellen white it's not quite the same way
you have to get
as in the bible as well what is the
individual thought there's a beautiful
passage in the
education page 127 paragraph one
with the word of god in his hand
every human being wherever his lot in
life may be cast
may have such companionship as he shall
choose
in its pages
he may hold converse with the noblest
and best of the human race and may
listen to the voice of the eternal as he
speaks with men
as he studies and meditates upon the
themes into which the angels desire to
look he may have their companionship he
may follow the steps of the heavenly
teacher and listen to his voice as when
he taught on mountain and plane and sea
he may dwell in this world in the
atmosphere of heaven imparting to
earth's soldering and tempted ones
thoughts of hope and longings for
holiness himself coming closer and still
closer into fellowship with the unseen
like him of old who walked with god
drawing nearer and narrow the threshold
of the eternal world until the portal
shall open and he shall enter in he
shall find himself no stranger the
voices that will greet him are the
voices of the holy ones voices who
unseen were on earth his companions
voices that here he learned to
distinguish and to love
he who through the word of god has lived
in fellowship with heaven will find
himself at home in heaven's
companionship what was she saying i had
to understand
the spirit of the passage of every
sentence to she's telling us you can
hang out with bible characters
literally hang out with them by studying
the word of god and their life daniel
joseph little capped whomever you can
hang out literally with bible characters
and by so doing the effect of their
character will change you
so that if you suddenly ended up in
heaven you'd feel at home because you've
been custom hanging out with moses and
david and joseph elijah
this is what she's saying and so once i
got that central message
one of the most beautiful passages i've
ever read in all of eloise writing
then i looked at every sentence
and you'll forget each sentence
and that's how i do it loy each sentence
but again it's over
and over
her writings
you cannot escape
constant repetition
everyone wants an easy way there's no
easy way you can't sleep with desired
ages under your pillow and wake up in
the morning and know it it doesn't work
like that you have to but the more you
do it the easier it becomes
we're not willing to try
you know you try for a week you memorize
whatever genesis 1 1 and after two days
you forget it and you give up in
discouragement no you say look i will
get this i'll die
or die trying
you try and then your mind becomes
stronger
and stronger
education page 123 paragraph one
for the mind and the soul as well as for
the body
it is god's law that strength is
acquired by effort
it is exercise that strengthens
both in the gym
and here
you don't build muscles going to the gym
and doing one rep
you don't build muscles by lifting
pillows are you following me you have to
lift weights
you sweat you grunt you groan you
collapse on the floor
but the muscles start to grow
spiritually you've got to do the same
thing are you with me
don't give up
remember this is for your spiritual
growth
this is for your spiritual strength your
defense against satan is thus
saith the lord at any age
and so my good sister i have no fancy
method my method is
brutal
bloody consistent repetition
you know what
there's some passages when i was working
on them the names they say where these
people get these names from jesus
you know genesis 40 came to pass in the
days of amrithal king of china ariel
king of elisa queda leoma king of elam
and title king of nation that these
midwives with bera king of sodom with
berserker king of gomorrah shine up king
of admiral shamiba king of the boy and
the king of bela which is zoa all these
were joined together in the veil of
sidon which is the salt sea twelve years
they served catalina and in the
thirteenth year they rebelled and in the
fourteenth year came kettle roma and the
kings that were with him and smote the
rephaims in ashtaroskar name and the
zuzims in ham and the eminence in
chavekyria theme now you've got to go
over that all the time all the time all
the time take medication to get it
because it it drives you nuts
but you say god i'll die i have to get
this
i have to get it
and to my amazement
it comes naturally then again abraham
took a wife
her name was kitura and she bear him
zimran and jokshan and maida and midian
and ishbak and sure abraham had six more
boys beside isaac and ishmael
genesis 25 six more boys i had to go
over those names go for this dave you
know esau had 12 sons
it was he saw yeah yes he saw it
and i had to
all the time all the time all the time
all the time all the time these strange
funny names you get into nehemiah oh you
talk about strange names
[Music]
but practice truly
makes perfect i was in south africa many
years ago
a member of the church was formerly a
professional golfer and he told me
every day he would drive the ball 600
times
to drive it to perfect the action 600
i read where kobe bryant and michael
jordan they would shoot a thousand jump
shots
you might miss 800 but he kept shooting
you have to apply this to god's word
in mark chapter 8 jesus told the
disciples i must go to jerusalem suffer
die rise again in mark 9 he said i must
go to jerusalem suffer die rise again in
mark 10 he tells them the same thing
they never got it immediately
you have to tell them tell them tell
them
repetition
also understanding what the verse is
saying
and a willingness to live by what you
learn
but i'm telling you again
if you practice if you try
you will become better at it you'll be
shocked how quickly there's a young
there's a young lady in zambia
she got my number somehow i don't know
how
text me
i have this kid i
so happy to have your number how can i
memorize i should just just try you in
college just try
she started memorizing chapters
sending me the recordings
and just like just i'm just delighted to
listen to those recording john 17 john
this you know jesus
chapters
he's a family
i hope they're not listening to this
i'll be crucified with a smile on their
faces
i
the mother of that family started
memorizing
working in proverbs got through the
first 10th chapter now proverbs is a
challenge
because each verse does not necessarily
follow or connect to the next she was up
to chapter 10
in proverbs
this little boy in
botswana memorized all of revelation
there's another little boy in there the
family sent me an audio of him
he was in a bathroom taking a shower
he's about five
but all he ever hears is hymns and the
bible because they live in the country
and the sound of birds and streams
that's all he is
so that's all he can say
and he was in the shower he was taking a
shower and he was preaching and romans
12 verse 1 says i beseech you there and
he's preaching he's preaching washing
him and the mother recorded him he
didn't know
and she sent it to me and i just smiled
and he had memorized romans
i said he memorized romans
amen he was five or six his other
brother memorized daniel
children are born with a mind that
absorbs like a sponge
we just have to make sure they absorb
the right because they will learn fast
we have to give them the right exposure
but we still have that mind our minds
were made to learn
forever try apply your mind and let your
mind be revived
try with god's word the writings of
ellen white
pastor skeet i think that that's a
fitting way to
cap off this
section and uh
you can you can talk to him individually
i'm sure
so but i i think that we've all been
inspired amen to hide the word of god in
our hearts
for those of you that are in the college
you know we have these these verse packs
this is this is a good way to do it fast
dan this was around when you were there
for a little bit right and uh so so i
want to encourage you to whatever it's
three by five cards or something like
this to to make this a part of our lives
if you've noticed a theme in his life
this is something that that is a part of
the fabric of his being something that
he does by god's grace throughout the
day it is his meditations truly day
and night
and let that be our experience amen
pastor skeet is not an anomaly it's not
an experience that no one else can have
this is available accessible to all by
god's grace and let us live by every
word that proceeds out of the mouth of
god praise his name pastor if you could
close us with prayer all right are there
any prayer requests
none
oh did you have a question
no okay all right
yes um his grandmother
and his sister passed away oh
he has to go to antigua tomorrow antigua
yeah okay he has to go home there to
funeralize them
that's a prayer request okay what's his
name yo
my name is glenn no no
you said your only son my oldest you
your oldest son yes sir he's going to
funeralize his mother uh-huh and his
youngest okay what's his name
his name is glenn his name is glenn his
mother name is
liza and his sister name is tia okay his
name i want his name his glenn glenn
what's glen's last name
lois lewis yes
okay okay all right we'll pray for
brother glenn you know one day there
will be no more death my brother
literally there will be no more death
the last enemy that shall be destroyed
is death
let me say it again you look as if you
didn't hear what i said
there's coming a day
when there will be you see we can get so
accustomed to something it's hard to
entertain the thought it will no longer
exist there is coming a day
when there will be no more death
i've heard people say what will i do in
heaven it'll be boring no it won't
you deal with a god who can find things
the universe is
give me a minute
what's the name of our galaxy come on
quickly the milky way
to travel from one end of the milky way
to the other at the speed of light
186 000 miles per hour per second sorry
it would take 200 000 years
did you hear what i said
to cross the milky way
which is one of billions of galaxies
it would require
000 years traveling at the speed of
light 186 000 miles per second now and a
bit now
there are worlds all over the universe
the bible says we will reign with christ
we have work to do
there is coming a time
there will be no more death
no sin
no sickness
but if the church can't believe that
but you see we are so surrounded by
death
by the animals plants people
everywhere you go there's a nice nicely
manicured graveyard
in every city
death
death ukraine wherever death death
it's hard to draw your mind and place
your mind on life without end but that
day is coming
and we have to so live our lives that
when christ comes and in uh ushers in
that new life
you and i
will be a part of it
i don't want to miss that just for
cigarette
or drugs
or a movie
or some worldly entertainment i don't
want to miss eternal life
for that
any other prayer request
let's bow our heads
our father in heaven we thank you so
much that your invitation to us is
let us therefore come boldly to the
throne of grace and we come in the name
of jesus dear god
if we offended you in any way forgive us
father you love to forgive micah 7 18
tells us he delighteth in mercy and
there's no greater mercy than calvary
dear god
lead us by your spirit into your word
let us find joy in studying your word in
meditating on your word as david said oh
how love i thy law it is my meditation
all the day
in his law doth he meditate day and
night the righteous man
remember brother glenn going to
funeralize relatives
let the spirit of comfort go within
their father let the angels defend him
and bless all of the family members give
them strength to deal with this great
loss
father
bless every student
in the academy in the college
bless the administrators their god give
them wisdom
that this institution may be a light in
this part of the world
give special wisdom to brother shin
father because leadership at any level
is not easy
give him the wisdom of solomon that he
may guide your people a right forward
and upward
provide the needs of the students
sustain the families that sacrifice to
send them to this place
bless us for the remainder of this holy
day i pray and even when the holy day
ends let us be reminded that our
holiness does not end
in jesus name we pray amen
in my state of michigan we still wear
these
so if you think i look like an alien i'm
not an alien
my wife has commanded me
to wear this or don't come back so i
have to wear this
so i thought i'd explain that so you
don't think i'm a strange but i'm
strange but not because of this
i have to release god bless you god
bless you i really mean that we see you
at
seven seven o'clock seven o'clock thank
you everyone memorize a verse between
then and now
and tell me what it is
[Music]
you